πολύ δύσκολη εξίσωση για ο πιο δήποται γιατί για αν θέλουμε να πάμε μπροστά όσο
ν αφορά την πράση τ μετάβαση του στόχους το ίκοσι τριάντα που έχει τέσ δια
υρωπαϊκή ενωσ είναι θα έλεγα αυτή στη μία ανέφικτη είμαστι στο ίκοικσπντ δεν έχουν γίεναι
αυτά από έπρεπε να γίνουν έκιναν κάποια βήματα αλλά δεν είναι αρκετά το θέμα τις
ηλεκτροκνησης δηλαδή τα ελεκτρικά αυτοκίνητα με τίποτα δεν θα πάρουμε του τόχους που έχουμε το
ίκοση τριάνα άρα το μήλα να με ένα αγκαλιάζονται και τόσο από τον κόσμοναελέγα δεν
έχει επεεξηγηθεί ποτέ τι σημαίνει πράσινη μετάβαση σε θέμα αριθμό γιατί αρχόμαστε και λέμε από
τη μια ότι το κόστος διαβίωσης είναι αυτή τη στιμή έχει καταστήσει ολλά ζευγάρει κι
ότο οκο γιναιακό ισόδημα έχει πιεστεί αφάνταστα είναι πολύ δύσκολο να επιβιώσει ένας μέσως πολύ
της αυτή τη στιγμή τουλάχιστον για να μπορέσει να έχει και όνερα για το μέλλο
καια από την άλλη πράσείνα με δάβαση η συγκυρία της πρασητης μετάβασης και ειδικότερα όταν
μιλάμε γιατ ίκόη κριάντα δεν μίλουμε για μακροπρόθεσμα μιλούμε για μια πένταϊτία αυτό είναι δηλαδή
βράχει πρόθεσμο άμεσο και δυστυχώς δεν υπάρχου μαϊκές λύσεις θα πρέπει να δούμε πωσμπορούμε να
πεγκλοβιστούμε από αυτή την κατάσταση γιατί από τη μια έχουμε δεί και τα τερά στη
αλάθει όσον αφορά το σχεδιασμό τ ενεργειακού μίγματος της κυπριακής δημοκρατίας που χουν μήνει στο
συρτάρια πάρα πολλές δεκαϊτίε ρα και το θέμαται πολέμουν στην ουκρανία με τη ρωσία έχει
επιδηνώσει την κατάστασ δηλαδή εναλλακτικές ακόμα καιια την ισαγωγύροσικού ετου φυσικόύ αρίου δεν μπρεί να
είναι απότληρωσία όλα αυτά ητάγιό πολιτικά επηρεάζουν κια τη και το κόστους διαδίωσης πράσινη μετάβαση
πράη είνα η χορολογία κάτι που επροπε να εφαρμοστεί από το κοσιδύο παίρναμε αναβολέσ στην
αναβολές καίνε ότι αυτό όλο θα το πληρώσουμε αναδρομικά με αποτέλεσμα σε μερικούς μήνες η
χρόνια να πάνε όλα πμα όταν μιλά με το μάιδηλαδή των επόμενο μήνα για να
πει πρα συνφορολογα γίνεται σε παρένθεση μια συσς